okay so in some of the earlier computer
file videos uh I talk about utility
functions or objective functions and we
got a lot of different comments relating
to that idea one thing people said was
well surely this kind of monom manical
following of a single utility function
at the cost of everything else is really
the cause of the problem in the first
place why even use a utility function or
maybe have several um conflicting ones
that interact with each other or
something like that some people asked
why do we assume that an AI will have a
utility function in the first place
aren't we making a pretty strong
assumption about the design of the AI
when in fact we don't know uh how it
would be implemented humans don't have
explicit utility functions that they
consult when they're making their
decisions uh a lot of different AI
designs people are working on now don't
have utility functions coded into them
explicitly so why make that kind of
unwarranted assumption so before we get
into that let's just go over what a
utility function is okay so here's the
Earth or the universe it can be in any
one of several different states so let's
just look at three possible World States
in this world I'm enjoying a pleasant
cup of tea in this world I've run out of
milk so the tea isn't quite how I'd like
it to be and in this world I'm being
stung by millions of wasps we want some
way of expressing that I have
preferences over these World States
some of them are better for me than
others so a utility function is a
function which takes as an argument a
world State an outputs a number saying
broadly speaking how good that world is
for me how much utility I get from it so
in this example perhaps a nice cup of
tea is worth 10 uh a mediocre cup of tea
is worth nine and the Wasps are minus a
th000 but Rob you might say that's way
too simple I care about all kinds of
things and what I what I love about the
world is is comp and nuanced you can't
distill everything down to just a single
number on each World State not with that
attitude you can and you kind of have to
but let's just forget about the numbers
for now and talk about preferences let's
make some basic assumptions about your
preferences the first one is that you do
have preferences given any two states of
the world you could decide which one you
would prefer to happen or you could be
indifferent but there's this basic
trilemma here for any pair of world
States A and B either a is preferable to
b or B is preferable to a or you're
indifferent between A and B it doesn't
matter to you which one happens always
exactly one of these things is true
hopefully that should be obvious but
just think about what it would mean for
it not to be true like what would it
mean to not prefer a to B not prefer B
to a and also not be indifferent between
b and a similarly what would it mean to
prefer a to B and simultaneously prefer
B to a if you're faced with a choice
then between A and B what do you
do the second basic assumption is
transitivity so you have this relation
between states is preferable too um and
you assume that this is transitive which
just means that if you prefer a to B and
you prefer B to C then you prefer a to c
again this seems intuitively pretty
obvious but let's look at what it would
mean to have intransitive preferences
let's say I prefer being in Amsterdam to
being in uh Beijing and I prefer being
in Beijing to being in
Cairo and I prefer being in Cairo to
being in Amsterdam what happens if I
have these preferences let's say I start
out in Amsterdam I prefer being in Cairo
so I get on a plane and I fly to Cairo
now I'm in Cairo and I find actually I
prefer being in Beijing so I get on a
plane I fly to Beijing I'm now in
Beijing and I say oh you know actually I
prefer to be in Amsterdam so I fly to
Amsterdam
and now I'm back where I started and hey
what do you know I prefer to be in Cairo
so you can see that if your preferences
aren't transitive you can get sort of
stuck in a loop where you just expend
all of your resources flying between
cities or in some other way changing
between options and this doesn't seem
very smart so if we accept these two
pretty basic assumptions about your
preferences then we can say that your
preferences are coherent you may have
noticed there's something else that has
these two properties which is the
greater than relation on numbers for any
two numbers A and B either a is greater
than b b is greater than a or A and B
are equal and if a is greater than B and
B is greater than C then a is greater
than C the fact that preferences and
numbers share these properties is
relevant here so if your preferences are
coherent they'll Define an order over
World states that is to say given your
preferences you could take every
possible World State and arrange them in
order of how good they are for you there
will be a single ordering over World
States you know there aren't any Loop
because your preference is a transitive
now if you have an ordering of world
states there will exist a set of numbers
for each World state that correspond to
that ordering perhaps you could just
take them all in order and give each one
a number according to where it falls in
the ordering so those are your utility
values for any coherent preferences
there will be a set of utility values
that exactly represents it and if you
have a utility value on every World
State well there will be some function
which takes in World States and returns
their utility values and that's your
utility function so if you have
consistent preferences you have a
utility function but Rob you may say I
don't have consistent preferences I'm a
human being my preferences are all over
the place that's true human beings do
not reliably behave as though they have
consistent preferences but that's just
because human intelligence is kind of
badly implemented our inconsistencies
don't make us better people it's not
some magic key to our Humanity or secret
to our Effectiveness or whatever it's
not making us smarter or more empathetic
or more ethical it's just making us make
bad decisions talking about utility
functions is actually a way of assuming
very little about the design of an AI
other than assuming that it has coherent
goal directed Behavior it doesn't matter
how it's implemented if it's effective
at navigating the world to get what it
wants it will behave as though it has a
particular utility function and this
means if you're going to build an agent
with coherent go directed Behavior you'd
better make sure it has the right
utility
function
[Music]
just wanted to say thank you to my
patreon supporters the three people who
somehow managed to support me before I
even mentioned in a video that I was
setting up a patreon and I especially
want to thank Chad Jones who's pledged
$10 a month thank you so much it really
means a lot to me that there are people
out there who think what I'm doing is
worth supporting so thanks again
fu